su cadera consta de dos partes
principales que se unen como una esfera
y una cavidad la cabeza femoral en la
parte superior de la pierna y el
acetábulo en su pelvis el cartílago
entre la cabeza femoral y el acetábulo
provee una amortiguación entre los
huesos y permite un movimiento suave un
reemplazo total de la pelvis se realiza
en general cuando un daño grave de
artritis o lesión dificulte el
desarrollo de las actividades diarias
sin dolor severo mi rango de movimiento
limitado durante el procedimiento la
cabeza femoral y el acetábulo se
reemplazan con elementos artificiales
llamados prótesis una prótesis de cadera
artificial consta de una copa llamada
componente acetabular y un vástago y
esfera llamado componente femoral antes
de su procedimiento recibirá líquidos
intravenosos antibióticos y medicamentos
para ayudarlo a relajarse los reemplazos
de cadera total anterior invasivo más
mínimos se realizan durante la anestesia
espinal por
estará despierto durante su operación
pero no sentirá el dolor es posible que
se le coloca un catéter en la vejiga
para drenar la orina debido a que la
pérdida de líquidos y sangre puede ser
significativa se preparará sangre de
reserva en caso de que necesite una
transfusión puede tener la oportunidad
de recolectar y almacenar su propia
sangre como preparación para su cirugía
durante un procedimiento de reemplazo de
cadera total anterior directa se
acostara boca arriba en una mesa
especializada lo que permitirá a su
cirujano realizar esta operación
mínimamente invasiva sus pies se
colocarán en botas adjuntas a la mesa lo
que permitirá a su cirujano colocar sus
piernas según sea necesario para ganar
acceso a su articulación de cadera
durante su operación se puede utilizar
una máquina de fluoroscopía durante el
procedimiento para ayudar a su cirujano
a colocar su prótesis con más exactitud
su cirujano comenzará al realizar una
incisión de 3 a 6 pulgadas cerca de su
ingle esta incisión es
significativamente más pequeña que
aquella realizada durante los
procedimientos de reemplazo total de
cadera
y empujar a dos músculos para exponer la
cápsula articular no se quiebran ni
separan músculos durante este
procedimiento después de la incisión de
la cápsula articular su cirujano
dislocara la cabeza femoral del
acetábulo y luego eliminar a cualquier
cartílago o hueso dañado en el acetábulo
volverá a dimensionar el receptáculo
acetabular y se ajustará la prótesis
acetabular en su lugar usando cemento
especial o tornillos dirigiéndose al
fémur su cirujano eliminará la cabeza
femoral dará forma al fémur restante
para ajustar el vástago protésico y
ajustará el componente femoral usando
cemento u otras técnicas una vez que
ambos componentes estén firmemente en su
lugar
el cirujano deslizará la cabeza femoral
prostética en su contraparte acetabular
probará el movimiento de su nueva
articulación de cadera y verificará que
esté colocada en forma correcta con una
radiografía
su cirujano luego cerrará la cápsula
articular y reposicionar a sus músculos
le colocará un drenaje en su cadera para
eliminar el líquido en exceso y cerrará
la incisión con puntos o grapas
después de su procedimiento lo enviarán
al área de recuperación posquirúrgica
para control seguirá con líquidos y
antibióticos intravenosos durante un
periodo de tiempo corto y recibirá
analgésicos según sea necesario si se
colocó un catéter se eliminará a fin de
evitar que se formen coágulos de sangre
en su pierna se le dará un
anticoagulante se le solicitará usar
medias de compresión y se fomentará que
empiece a caminar lo más pronto posible
en un principio con un andador o bastón
su médico usará un dispositivo de
compresión secuencial en sus piernas o
pies para disminuir más la posibilidad
de desarrollar un coágulo de sangre
llamado trombosis venosa profunda tvp en
las venas de sus piernas no son
necesarias las precauciones con las
caderas puede sentarse hacer flexiones y
cruzar sus piernas siempre que lo desee
se le dará el alta del hospital después
de que suba y baje las escaleras por lo
general después de 2 a 4 días
el enfoque previo evita el corte de
cualquier músculo de las caderas que
pueda derivar en
mayor estabilidad de articulación menor
riesgo de deslocalización más rápida